tu as regardé la vidéo de McFly et
carlitoù ils Mang des piments ils ont
posé une question intéressante les gens
disent la chiasse la chiasse la chiasse
est-ce qu'il y a une il y a une
corrélation entre piment et chiass là on
n pas la réponse dans les piments il y a
une substance qui s'appelle la capsacine
ils en parlent dans la vidéo cette
substance elle fait deux choses elle
irrite les muqueuses de ton tupe
digestif et elle accélère le mouvement
de tes intestins résultat ça pique et ça
donne la diarhée mais on n'est pas tous
égau j'ai demandé à des participants à
out ones géromel ça lui a donné super
mal au ventre et le cul qui pique mais
il a pas eu la diarrée et Monsieur poup
juste une toute petite mais il a manger
du riz avant et après malin par contre
attention ça donne l'illusion que c'est
chaud alors que c'est pas chaud mais la
capsaïine ça hrite pour de vrai c'est ce
qu'on met dans les lacririmau elle a des
vrais effets sur le corps on en fait
même des médicaments plus on en prend
plus nos récepteurs s'habituent ça
s'appelle le phénomène de tolérance mais
éviter le piment si vous avez un ulcère
à l'estomac ou une maladie inflammatoire
des intestins ou si vous allitez parce
que ça passe dans le lait et ça irrite
l'intestin du bébé voilà voilà